so we begin with breaking news out of
Gabon where a group of senior military
leaders have announced they are in
charge of the country and have put the
president under house arrest that's just
days after a controversial election in
the oil-rich African nation well the
military leaders appeared on National
Television to announce the cancellation
of Saturday's election result the
Electoral commission had said president
alibongo won a third term in office the
military have also dissolved all
institutions well that announcement
triggered celebrations on the streets of
the capital libreville hundreds turned
out there had been criticism of the
government for the way Saturday's
election was organized
now in just a moment we'll be speaking
to our correspondence covering all
aspects of this story for us we have
Catherine soy in Kenya's Capital Nairobi
we had Natasha Butler she'll be giving
reaction to the events in Gabon from
Paris Ahmed Idris is in niger's capital
Naomi and we have Nicholas hack in
Senegal's capital Dakar but first this
report from Stephanie Decker
foreign
it was just before 6am when Gabon woke
up to this
after noting an irresponsible
unpredictable governance which results
in a continuous deterioration of social
cohesion that risks leading the country
to chaos today the 30th of August 2023
in the name of the gabonese people we
the committee of the transition and the
restoration of Institutions have decided
to defend the peace putting an end to
the regime in place
senior Military Officers appearing on
National Television announcing the
seizure of power
that happened soon after the country's
election body announced that president
alibongo had won a third term in office
the president put under house arrest and
now this video has emerged and I'm to
send a message to all the friends
that we have all over the world to tell
them to make noise to make noise for the
people here have arrested me
and my family
but many people in the capital
libreville have been welcoming and
celebrating the news
The Bongo era the bongoism is over that
was clearly something that any analyst
who is serious about African politics
could see happening and truly uh Ali
Bongo was no longer in the hearts of the
populations in Gabon he was not accepted
by the opposition that was this time
around very strong behind its candidates
its main candidate Albert Honda also and
also there was some problem between Ari
Bongo and France
opposition candidates complained of
missing ballot papers for the general
election on Saturday rights
organizations condemned the ban on
foreign media and international
observers government leaders cut
internet access in imposed a night
curfew after the elections raising
concern about transparency
both previous wins by Bongo were also
challenged as fraudulent by opposition
candidates
Bongo has ruled oil Rich Gabon since his
father and previous president died in
2009 the family has governed the country
for 56 years
Bongo suffered a stroke in 2018 which
incapacitated him for almost a year
increasing calls for him to step aside
a failed coup attempt followed in 2019
when soldiers who mutinied were killed
or jailed
the military has released this video
showing soldiers celebrating following
the announcement gabon's borders are now
closed and all state institutions
dissolved Stephanie Decker Al Jazeera
speak now to our correspondent Nick hack
he joins us from Dhaka in Senegal first
of all Nick just bring us up to speed
with what's the latest that we're
hearing from Gabon on this day
well there's this extraordinary video
circulating on social media widely being
shared in Libre villain in Gabon one of
the president Ali Bongo who up until
last night appeared Invincible at the
helm of this family Dynasty that has
been in power for the last 56 years
years he appeared weak
calling for help
um inside house arrest his own
presidential Palace an extraordinary
moment for a lot of Japanese who have
seen him rule or his family rule for so
long and this has really sparked
celebrations that we're seeing right now
in the streets of the Capitol we're
hearing that even soldiers are offering
drinks to those that are celebrating on
the streets with people chanting Gabon
is finally free this is really a turning
point for the history of Gabon but
certainly for this former French Colony
that has strong and import links to to
friends
Laura so Nick we're also getting some
information now on who has led this coup
what do we know about him
yes his name is
and he was in fact the head of the
presidential guard the man responsible
to protect Ali Bongo from such military
coups well now he's the one that's
detaining alibongo under house arrest
now he was a close Ally to alibongo he
was also
a close aide to his father Omar Bongo
who was the previous president but
interestingly enough he was also named
in a coup attempt in 2019 when Ali Ali
Bongo suffered from a stroke and then he
was dispatched to Dakar Senegal where he
was the military attache he has been
trained in Morocco and he is the head of
the presidential guard we saw him shake
hands with uh president Emmanuel macron
back in June when there was an official
visit of alibongo there at the Elise so
he's known to the French he's been in in
around the the power of alibanco or in
the Spheres of alibanga what's
extraordinary is these military juntas
now that have not only arrested alibongo
but also his son and Close Associates
going on National Television accusing
the accusing them of high treason
charging them with
um trafficking with corruption with
emptying State coffers and on National
Television we saw the the soldiers
saying that they will be brought to
Justice something that many gabonese who
live in poverty in this oral uh wealthy
country have been waiting for Laura
brings the latest there on events in
Gabon thanks very much Nick well the
situation the in Gabon it marks the 10th
coup or attempted takeover in West and
central Africa in the last three years
Regional leaders are still trying to
negotiate a return to democracy in Niger
after last month's coup there makina
Faso saw two coups last year in the
second instance Captain Ibrahim tarore
forced out his own military colleague
last September in 2021 Ghanaian soldiers
took part from president Alpha Conde who
was seeking a controversial third term
and Mali has also seen two coups since
2020 both of them orchestrated by the
current leader asimi goeta
Ahmed Idris joins us now live from Naomi
that's the capital of Niger where the
last military coup took place just last
month and we're hearing some people
already calling this a francophone
spring are we seeing a pattern here
exactly there is a pattern and most of
all these scores you're talking about in
the introduction are fueled by
disenchantment with the leadership in
the various francophone countries and of
course with the relationship between the
leadership and France especially in this
space of economy and defense people are
talking about despite the presence of
France especially in this hell a
violence still continues and our armed
groups are like Al-Qaeda and isil are
holding vast territory in some of these
sahelian countries I spoke to one
political and political and security
analyst here just a few hours ago and he
said the situation developing now in
Gabon sort of validates or justifies
what people in Asia have all been have
been talking about all the time that
there has been a neglect a total neglect
of the voting population and of course
the romance between their leaders and
Friends
leads to the sort of the over
exploitation of resources with little to
show for the ordinary person on the
street so there is this widespread
disenchantment and of course anti-french
sentiment spreading across the cell and
now there are concerns that this will
spread even further Beyond uh
francophone countries so now that many
of the countries we're talking about
democratically elected governments are
still struggling to deliver uh democracy
dividends to their people indeed so what
are you hearing from the Niger Street
what are people there saying about the
latest coup in Gabon
people are really really uh saying that
this is uh it's about time it's about
time to cut ties to France it's about
time to liberate ourselves we haven't
seen Gabon or protesters and gabono
celebrants in Gabon uh flashing Russian
uh Chinese or even North Korean Flags
the way we saw them here in Niger but in
just situation is probably different
from what obtains in uh in in Gabon
simply because Nigeria is struggling
with security issues here and it's also
struggling economically the level of
poverty here is really really striking
and people are really disenchanted that
poverty with widespread now and there is
little to show for it and right now they
believe that what they have uh in in
place now the military government here
could of course cut ties with France and
probably struck a new deal with the
countries of the East especially China
and Russia Ahmed address report there
from Naomi Amnesia thanks very much
Ahmed
well the whole world has been reacting
to the coup in Gabon French prime
minister Elizabeth Bourne said France
gabon's former Colonial ruler was
following the situation closely China
meanwhile is calling for the safety of
President Bongo to be guaranteed by the
coup leaders and the eu's foreign policy
Chief Joseph Burrell has expressed
concern for the stability of the whole
region after yet another military coup
let's join Natasha Butler in Paris now
Natasha you're outside the gabonese
embassy there in the French Capital what
are people saying there
foreign
dozens of people have gathered here
outside uh the Japanese Embassy in Paris
in the center in A very upscale area in
fact an area where the Bongo family
owned a lot of real estate huge real
estate portfolio in Paris has often been
the source of some controversy and
people have been celebrating I'm going
to step out of the way and we're going
to pan around and show you some people
dancing now waving uh Flags a few more
people are coming and what some of them
have been telling me is that they feel
as if today is a new day for Gabon they
feel as if this is a peaceful a
revolution they all hope for a peaceful
transition and for democracy and they've
also been talking a lot about France the
former colonial power they say that they
feel that France has had ample
opportunity to support the Japanese
people rather than the Bongo family this
feeling that Francis for so long had
these ties with the Bongo family
supported them even though people here
say that Omar Bongo the former leader of
Gabon and Ali Bongo both of them they
say have done very little for ordinary
people have done very little to
modernize the country and had they done
so then perhaps they would have been
supported but as they've done nothing
this is what people have been saying
they need to move on and France needs to
understand that people in Gabon wanted
to be in control of Their Own Destiny
and does France understand that what's
been the reaction of the French
political Elite
we've heard from the French prime
minister Elizabeth borns borns Paris is
watching the situation very closely also
from the spokesperson for the French
government saying that they Paris
condemns the coup d'etat that Paris has
called on people in Gabon to uphold and
respect the results of the recent
elections so certainly that clashes uh
with what people here are saying because
many of them have said that this
election was not free was not fair and
therefore those results as far as they
are concerned are null and void so
that's what we've been hearing here in
French political circles no surprise
perhaps because France has long had
these ties with the leadership in Gabon
there are a number of military personnel
and Gabon on a French base there are a
lot of French interests in Gabon in
terms of large multinationals total
energy for example the big energy uh
giant uh arumet a big mining giant
Aramis actually said that it's
suspending its operations in the country
and seeing how the situation develops
there is no doubt that many French
businesses will be concerned about what
is happening in Gabon but as I said
people here are saying that's part of
the problem that those businesses have
been are making a lot of money that
money has been leaving the country and
it's now not been spread amongst the
population The Ordinary People in Gabon
and that is why we need to change this
circle this network of alliances between
Paris and libreville that has really
only helped the privileged and left
others behind Natasha Butler bring us
the view that from outside the Gabon
Embassy in Paris thanks very much
Natasha
okay well let's go back onto the African
continent now we can go to Nairobi where
we can speak to Catherine soy because
Catherine you were just trying to get to
Gabon for Saturday's presidential
election but you fail to get
accreditation talk us through what
happened and why
yes and uh we I have been talking to
many people in Gabon
um throughout this election period and
yes we have been trying to get
accreditation
um to travel to the country and uh cover
the election it's been uh three weeks
um trying to get that it was not
possible and we are not just talking
about us Al Jazeera um other
International journalists who are also
denied accreditation as well and we also
know that our International
observers like the US and the European
Union and others who are also denied
accreditation so they were not able uh
to observe the elections in uh Gabon and
that's why a lot of people that we've
talked to in Gabon say that they do not
believe that that election was credible
um they are very frustrated raise it as
well those ones that we have been
talking to and we have seen through the
weeks a lot of changes that were made by
the Electoral commission changes
pertaining to uh the election and the
procedures
um as well we are so in the lead up to
the election we saw the internet being
shot down we so
um curfews that were imposed as well and
you know during their campaign period
itself on the on the last day of
campaigns uh president Ali Bongo when he
made his speech he said that he knows
that there are some individuals who are
trying to overthrow the government and
we have also been hearing
um throughout that time
um ruling party officials who were very
very uncomfortable about this grouping
of opposition leaders um presidential
candidates who endowed a single uh
presidential candidate and this had not
happened before so there was a lot of uh
jitteriness a lot of people in the
ruling party were very uncomfortable
about that and that's why we saw this
very fast development the internet cut
off and things like that as well so we
were in Gabon in 2016 covering the
election there
um that election was disputed as well
the LA the um the the the the the
opposition leader then
um
that the the opposition leader then
um said that to the election was Riggs
there was post-election uh violence
people died other others were injured as
well so right now the gabonese uh who
lived without and for that
frustration uh say that they just wanted
change and they're seeing this change
and they're very happy about it indeed
okay Catherine thanks very much for
bringing us a little bit of context
there Catherine soy reporting from
Nairobi let's speak now to Murray Roger
beloa she's the editor of Africa
International and joins us from Yandy in
Cameroon great to have you with us I
just want to bring you some news that
we're getting in from the African Union
calling an urgent meeting with Burundi
Senegal and Cameroon to analyze the
situation in Gabon the Au calling it a
coup attempt what do you make of that
well uh as soon as the dust is not
settled yet we are not sure that the
crew has been successful but there are
many signs that cross uh I mean the
African Union is an official
organization they need to to make
official statements but what we see in
the streets what we see
um happening hour by hour uh looks like
uh the coup is now done
and
I mean in central Africa uh everybody
has been turning
um the the the view of the eyes to uh
towards South Central Africa but uh the
situation is I would say quite different
in a way that uh
um the the main trigger of coup d'etat
in West Africa is in security to
that set of issues and in central Africa
we have uh president who's been here for
a while uh some of them for a very long
time uh but Gabon it was is a specific
case where in uh in 14 years there was
not a single uh free and fair election
and it the process was always very
brutal with debts and casualties like
what the previous uh interviewer said
and um yeah and more of a and on top of
it the president
uh was physically unfit to to govern
toward the country but he didn't want to
back down to retire and uh and that was
being felt as very irresponsible uh and
uh so for five years uh we we just have
news of about his health we see very
embarrassing scenes of him over the
world's stage uh uh you know showcasing
his illness and his weakness so the
Japanese and Africans are in general are
very we're very embarrassed and in the
meantime the county was not governed I
mean if you see all the criteria economy
helps education you name it everything
is sorry in a heart uh and uh the the
Japanese opposition was very responsible
because I'm quite interested to see uh
what the feeling is in neighboring
Cameroon because there you've got a
leader who's 90 years old so in a rather
similar situation one might say to
alebongo where I should imagine people
are looking at his health and his
longevity how worried should he be that
he might be next
okay uh uh of course since the the there
are there is this cool epidemic as they
call it in West Africa people think of
the situation in central Africa and many
in several countries as well
um and you can feel some kind of anxiety
or people think you definitely I'm
definitely sure that it people think of
of it also in Cameroon but the situation
is quite different
um because since the coup the attempt in
um army and all security forces have
been so divided and organized in a way
that a coup is very very difficult I
don't see it's impossible but it's very
very difficult to succeed you can try
something but uh the the chances that
you you get it to you bring that to an
end are very thin
so
um and also what we see is that uh
people have sort of accepted that the
current president will finish his term
and maybe we'll die in power and they
are waiting for what will happen next
okay I just want to get another question
in because you are normally based in
Paris and many of these leaders where we
have seen in countries of where we've
seen these coups have been called
puppets of the French these are
ex-colonial countries do you think that
is true is that a fair assessment that
they remain puppets of the French
that gaboon
um
the government is a country which has
been traditionally very close to France
and the first president after
Independence uh leonba used to say we
have our loyalty goes to two countries
to France and to Gabon you know so uh
and uh the whole transfer Gabon has been
considered as the heart of the famous
francophrique system you know uh and uh
the former president bungu Ali bongo's
father was a very uh I would say
respected figure in in that system he
was he was really the core of the system
uh but now Ali Bongo has been trying to
Showcase some kind of in the
independence because for instance he
joined the Commonwealth where they even
if they have no tradition uh with
English or we've written
but they decided to show Independence in
in joining that Organization for
instance okay this kind of thing but
basically uh you know France companies
are still very strong there and I would
say the cultural eyes are very strong
okay Murray Roger below we have to leave
it there but thanks so much taking the
time to join us there from Cameron